HAVE A GREAT NIGHT, EVERYONE.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: A GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
FOR MOST AMERICANS WHO DON’T
LIVE IN NEW YORK CITY, NEW YORK
IS A LOT LIKE YOUR HALF DRUNK
NE’ER-DO-WELL UNCLE APPEARED
FLASHY, LOUD, ALWAYS
BRAGGING ABOUT HIMSELF, THOUGH
SOMEWHAT LESS IMPRESSIVE THAN HE
CLAIMS TO BE.
YOU LOVE YOUR UNCLE, YOU JUST
DON’T WANT TO KNOW TOO MUCH
ABOUT HIS PERSONAL LIFE.
THERE’S NO QUESTION IT IS MESSY
AND WEIRD.
YOU EXPECT HE OWES A LOT OF
PEOPLE MONEY, HE EATS WITH HIS
MOUTH OPEN.
STILL, HE’S YOUR UNCLE.
YOUR LIVES ARE INTERTWINED.
IF YOU GET SOME TERRIBLE DISEASE
AND EYES, YOU’LL BE SAD ABOUT
IT.
IN NEW YORK IS THE SAME WAY.
EVEN IF YOU DISLIKE NEW YORK TOO
MUCH TO VISIT, YOU SHOULD CARE
WHAT HAPPENS THERE BECAUSE
YOU’RE AN AMERICAN AND NEW YORK
IS BY FAR THIS COUNTRY’S BIGGEST
CITY.
NEW YORK IS MORE THAN TWICE AS
MANY PEOPLE, SECOND PLACE IS
LOS ANGELES.
IT’S PHYSICALLY TINY, THE ENTIRE
CITY OF MANHATTAN IS SMALLER
THAN THE DALLAS AIRPORT, BUT
NEW YORK IS 10% OF OUR TOTAL GDP
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO WHAT HAPPENS TO YOU NEW YORK
MATTERS TO THE REST OF US, LIKE
THE PLACE OR NOT.
RECENTLY, NEW YORK SEEMED TO BE
THRIVING.
OFFICIAL THEORISTS SUCCEEDED IN
DOING THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
THING CIVIC LEADERS CAN DO, THEY
MADE THEIR CITY SAFE FOR NORMAL
PEOPLE TO LIVE THERE.
NEW YORK IS ONE OF THE LEAST
DANGEROUS METRO AREAS IN THE
WORLD.
THEY BRAGGED ABOUT IT.
THERE IS NO MYSTERY HOW THEY DID
IT.
THE CITY HIRED TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF COPS.
THEY THREW CRIMINALS AND
ANTISOCIAL DESTROYERS IN JAIL
AND LEFT THEM THERE, AND IT
WORKED.
NEW YORK IMPROVED DRAMATICALLY.
PEOPLE WITH CHOICES, PEOPLE
COULD LIVE ANYWHERE, WANTED TO
LIVE THERE.
AND THEN IN A SHORT SPACE OF
TIME, MAYOR BILL de BLASIO
ARRIVED AND HE SAID ABOUT
REVERSING THE FORMULA.
ON THE BASIS OF NO EVIDENCE,
de BLASIO ATTACKED THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT OF NEW YORK AS
RACIST.
HE THEN CUT A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE NYPD BUDGET.
IT DEMORALIZED COPS STOPPED
MAKING ARRESTS AND ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY, CRIME AND VIOLENCE
IN THE CITY EXPLODED.
IN A SINGLE MANHATTAN
NEIGHBORHOOD, THE UPPER EAST
SIDE, ROBBERIES HAVE JUMPED BY
286% THIS YEAR.
THINGS FELL APART.
NEW YORKERS WHO COULD LEAVE THE
CITY DID LEAVE.
THE ENTIRE TAX BASE FLEEING TO
FLORIDA.
BILL de BLASIO WATCHED THESE
ENTIRELY PREDICABLE THINGS
HAPPENED, GLASSY EYED, BREATHING
THROUGH HIS MOUTH, PROBABLY TOO
HIGH TO PROCESS IT ALL APPEARED
IN THE END, de BLASIO
CONCLUDED THAT NONE OF IT WAS HI
NEW YORKERS, HE DECIDED, HAVE
HAD IT TOO EASY.
WHAT THEY NEED IS MORE
SUFFERING.
TODAY, de BLASIO ANNOUNCED
THAT HE CLAIMS TO ENCIRCLE THE
ENTIRE CITY WITH MILITARY STYLE
CHECKPOINTS, NOT TO STOP VIOLENT
CRIMINALS, BUT TO PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM VISITING FROM OTHER PLACES.
THERE WAS NO PUBLIC DISCUSSION
OF THIS AHEAD OF TIME, THERE WAS
NO DEBATE.
de BLASIO JUST DECREED IT.
>> STARTING TODAY, WE’RE GOING
TO DO SOMETHING NEW IN
NEW YORK CITY.
WE WILL HAVE CHECKPOINTS AT KEY
ENTRY POINTS TO THE CITY.
TRAVELERS COMING IN FROM THOSE
STATES WILL BE GIVEN INFORMATION
ABOUT THE QUARANTINE, THEY’LL
WILL BE REMINDED THAT IT IS
REQUIRED, NOT OPTIONAL.
THEY’LL BE REMINDED THAT FAILURE
TO QUARANTINE IS A VIOLATION OF
STATE LAW, AND IT COMES WITH
SERIOUS PENALTIES.
TAX UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES,
FINES COULD BE AS HIGH AS
$10,000.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT?
IT DOESN’T MAKE ANY SENSE AT
ALL, HE DIDN’T BOTHER TO EXPLAIN
WHY THEY’RE DOING IT, THERE IS
NO SCIENCE BEHIND IT.
BUT THE ONE THING YOU KNOW FOR
SURE IS IT’S YOUR FAULT.
NOT HIS, YOURS.
YOUR FAILURES ARE A SEVERE
VIOLATION OF THE LAW, SAYS
BILL de BLASIO.
YOU’LL BE PUNISHED IF YOU
DISOBEY.
YOU ARE BAD.
TRAVELERS FROM NEW YORK CITY ARE
ABOUT TO LEARN A VERY IMPORTANT
LESSON.
IT’S A LESSON THAT THOSE FROM
NURSING HOMES IN ERA, THOSE WHO
SURVIVED THEM HAVE ALREADY
LEARNED, AND IT’S THIS: THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE WORST
DECISIONS, THE DECISION TO KILL
PEOPLE, NEVER FACE CONSEQUENCES
FOR THOSE DECISIONS.
ONLY YOU DO, SO SHUT UP AND SHOW
US YOUR PAPERS, PEASANT.
ONE OF THE IRONIES, AND THERE
ARE MANY, IS THAT EARLIER THIS
YEAR NEW YORK THREATEN TO SUE
RHODE ISLAND FOR TRYING TO SET
UP THE VERY SAME CHECKPOINTS.
AT THE TIME, ANDREW CUOMO, THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK, CALLED
CHECKPOINTS LIKE THIS
"UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND
REACTIONARY."
SO WHAT CHANGED?
WELL, WHO KNOWS.
DON’T WASTE YOUR TIME LOOKING
FOR CONSISTENCY.
BUREAUCRACIES DON’T HAVE TO BE
CONSISTENT BECAUSE THEY ARE IN
CHARGE.
THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
THEY DON’T HAVE TO EXPLAIN WHY.
AT THE VERY MOMENT THAT THEY’VE
DECIDED TO TREAT TAXPAYERS OF
NEW YORK LIKE REFUGEES IN A WAR
ZONE WITH CHECKPOINTS, LEADERS
IN NEW YORK SEEMED TO BE DOING
ALL THEY CAN TO MAKE LIFE EASIER
FOR THUGS WITH GUNS.
BACK IN MAY, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
CITY OF NEW YORK RELEASED A GANG
MEMBER FROM CUSTODY WITHOUT
BAIL.
HE HAD BEEN CHARGED WITH
ATTEMPTED MURDER BUT THEY JUST
LET HIM GO.
HERE ARE PICTURES OF THE ALLEGED
CRIME.
IMAGINE LETTING THAT GUY, THE
GUY WITH THE GUN SHOOTING
SOMEONE ON THE SIDEWALK, JUST
WALK OUT FREE.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
YOU WOULD HAVE TO HATE THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN YOUR SETTING
IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
PROSECUTORS SAY THAT THAT
SUSPECT, A MAN CALLED DARIUS
SUTTON, WENT ON AFTER NEW YORK
LET HIM OUT TO COMMIT THREE MORE
SHOOTINGS BECAUSE OF COURSE HE
DID.
BILL de BLASIO DOESN’T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT ANY OF THAT.
HE DOESN’T WANT YOU TO TALK
ABOUT IT, EITHER.
THE THING ABOUT SOCIAL JUSTICE
IS YOU ARE JUST GOING TO HAVE TO
IGNORE THE DETAILS.
INSTEAD, CITY OFFICIALS WOULD
LIKE YOU TO STAY TERRIFIED OF
THE CORONAVIRUS BECAUSE MORE
ANXIETY ABOUT INVISIBLE VIRUSES
WILL TAKE YOUR MIND OFF THE
SHOOTINGS AND THE DECAY.
SO IN A FEW DAYS, NEW YORK WILL
BEGIN FOLLOWING AND HARASSING
TRAVELERS.
THEY GOING TO TEXT AND CALL YOU
IF YOU PLAN TO TRAVEL AND IF YOU
DON’T RESPOND, CITY WORKERS MAY
COME TO YOUR HOME IN PERSON.
LISTEN TO A MAN CALLED TED LONG
EXPLAINED THE PLAN.
HE RUNS SOMETHING CALLED THE
TEST AND TRACE CORE IN NEW YORK.
>> TOMORROW, WE ARE GOING TO BE
DEPLOYING TEAMS TO PENN STATION
TO STOP TRAVELERS TO MAKE SURE
THEY’VE COMPLETED THE TRAVEL
FORM.
WE’VE MADE MORE THAN 86,000
PHONE CALLS TO TRAVELERS COMING
INTO NEW YORK CITY FROM THE
DESIGNATED HIGH RISK STATES, AND
WE’VE SENT MORE THAN 20,000 TEXT
MESSAGES TO DATE.
AND IF WE CAN’T GET THROUGH TO
YOU ON THE PHONE, WE DEPLOY
TEAMS THAT ARE NOW KNOCKING ON
YOUR DOOR TO CHECK IN WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: OH, SO TED LONG IS
GOING TO DEPLOY TEAMS TO
PENN STATION.
HAVE YOU BEEN TO PENN STATION
RECENTLY?
IT’S A HOMELESS SHELTER, THE
WHOLE THING!
OH, THERE’S A GUY WITH HIS
TROUSERS DOWN RELIEVING HIMSELF
IN THE CORNER.
OH, THEY’RE DEALING CRACK OVER
HERE, OH, THEY’RE SMOKING IT
OVER HERE.
GO TO PENN STATION AND ASK
YOURSELF, IS THIS AMERICA?
BUT TED LONG WILL DEPLOY TEAMS
TO HASSLE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRAVELING TO NEW YORK TO HELP
THE CITY STAY AFLOAT.
RIGHT.
KEEP IN MIND, THE PREHUMAN
LITTLE LECTURE YOU JUST HEARD
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH COMES FROM
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO FORCED
CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS INTO
NURSING HOMES AND KILLED PEOPLE
BY DOING IT.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO LET VIOLENT
RIOTERS CONTROLLED THE CITY
STREETS BUT SUDDENLY, THEY’RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR HEALTH
RIGHT.
WHAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT, AS ALWAYS, IS MAINTAINING
POLITICAL CONTROL.
AND OF COURSE MONEY.
MONEY IS SUDDENLY PRESSING
CONCERN FOR THEM, AND THE MAIN
PROBLEM IS, AND THEY ARE GOING
TO FIX THIS IF THEY CAN, IS THAT
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM IT’S
PRETTY DIFFICULT TO FORCE PEOPLE
TO REMAIN IN CRUMBLING CITIES
BECAUSE FOR NOW, WE STILL HAVE
FREEDOM OF MOVEMENT.
RICH PEOPLE ARE RUNNING AWAY
FROM NEW YORK.
THEY HAVE MORE FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT THAN ANYONE BECAUSE
THEY CAN AFFORD TO GO ANYWHERE
THEY WANT, AND THEY SEE WHAT’S
COMING.
IT’S PRETTY OBVIOUS.
THE PLAN TO BE SOMEWHERE ELSE
WHEN IT ARRIVES.
THIS RAISES THE QUESTION OF WHO
IS GOING TO PAY FOR ALL THESE
FAILED AND POISONOUS SOCIAL
EXPERIMENTS, THE ONES THAT
TURNED A TRAIN STATION INTO A
HOMELESS SHELTER IN MIDTOWN.
ANDREW CUOMO IS SMART ENOUGH TO
BE WORRIED ABOUT THIS.
HE IS NOW BEGGING MILLIONAIRES
TO COME BACK TO THE HELL HOLE HE
HELPED CREATE.
>> WE USED TO BE WORRIED THAT
MILLIONAIRE TAX PEERS MIGHT
LEAVE.
NOW WE ARE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
TO COME BACK.
I TALK TO PEOPLE ALL DAY LONG
WHO ARE IN THE HAMPTONS, WHO
ALSO LIVE HERE OR IN THEIR
HUDSON VALLEY HOUSE, OR IN THEIR
CONNECTICUT HOUSE, AND I SAY,
YOU GOT TO COME BACK, WHEN YOU
COMING BACK?
WE WILL GO TO DINNER, I’LL BUY
YOU A DRINK, COME OVER, I’LL
COOK.
THEY ARE NOT COMING BACK RIGHT
NOW.
>> Tucker: IT’S PATHETIC, IT’S
PATHETIC.
OH, THERE IN THE HAMPTONS HOUSE.
COME BACK TO NEW YORK, IT’S
GREAT.
I’LL MEET YOU AT PENN STATION,
WILL GET A BURGER AND SOME
HEPATITIS.
YEAH.
IT TURNS OUT RICH PEOPLE MAY BE
EVIL BUT IN THE END YOU NEED A
FEW OF THEM TO PAY FOR
EVERYTHING, OTHERWISE YOU HAVE
NO POLITICAL POWER.
THAT’S AN OBVIOUS TRUTH TRUTH TH
CUOMO IS SAYING.
THE CITY’S POTHEAD MAYOR CAN’T
EVEN SAY THAT OUT LOUD.
IT’S POSSIBLE HE MAY NOT EVEN
UNDERSTAND THE PRINCIPLE, BUT
BILL de BLASIO DOES KNOW HIS
DISINTEGRATING CITY WILL NEED
MONEY FROM SOMEWHERE AND SOON,
SO HE’S THINKING THE REST OF
AMERICA SHOULD PAY FOR HIS
DISASTER.
>> IF WE DO NOT GET FEDERAL
SUPPORT SOON, AND AM VERY
WORRIED ABOUT THESE STIMULUS
TALKS IN WASHINGTON BECAUSE THEY
SEEM TO BE GOING NOWHERE FAST,
MY CHALLENGE IS WHERE OUR WE
GOING TO HAVE THE PEOPLE TO
DO THIS WORK?
I MAY HAVE TO DO LAYOFFS AS OF
MANY OF 22,000 CITY EMPLOYEES
FROM EVERY DEPARTMENT BY OCTOBER
FEDERAL HELP.
>> Tucker: SO CONSULT YOUR
BILL de BLASIO CHEAT SHEET.
LOOK IT UP, WE KEEP OURS RIGHT
HERE.
IF YOU WELCOMING YOU WILL SEE
THAT IT WAS LESS THAN A MONTH
AGO THAT THE SAME MAN,
BILL de BLASIO, THREATENED TO
SUE THE GOVERNMENT IF THEY
HELPED TOO MUCH.
IF THEY DEPLOYED FEDERAL LAW
OFFICERS TO THE CITY.
NOW HE IS WHINING THAT THE FEDS
AREN’T DOING ENOUGH.
SHAMELESS?
OBVIOUSLY, OF COURSE IT IS.
YET TO BE FAIR, IT’S POSSIBLE